so a slightly disappointing result for
you how are you feeling about this
ruling well I expected to find out what
comes out what happens when a victim of
libel and slander goes to court in
Germany against facebook and we learned
a lot of things today of course I would
have liked to win but we have found out
that with the current law we have in
Germany it will be impossible or at
least extremely difficult to remove
illegal content on Facebook do you
envision contesting this ruling in any
way it is very likely that this ruling
could be contested and that new aspects
or even completely different verdict
could come out if Anna's mother money
were to go to a bum bag which would be
the next higher court for most of all a
main proceeding would be necessary to
clarify a lot of those questions that
were left open today we've learned that
the question of whether it needs a
wonder machine for facebook to find
identical pictures on the honor system
requires a main proceeding curse in this
preliminary injunction the courts that
is what was unable to make a decision on
whether or not it was possible ok you
mentioned this this you believe that
this process had sent a message what
kind of message were you talking about
well what we have learned today is that
if we wanted to enforce German law on
facebook we will need different laws
even if we had won this case it has been
it has taken ten weeks for this picture
to be taken down it actually is still
online as we speak today and this does
not make sense it needs Facebook to
delete illegal content what we will need
is real incentives for facebook to
remove illegal content currently
Facebook is doing ok by just saying we
don't care about German law we don't
take down content that we like that
makes traffic and that we make money
with and therefore there's no reason for
facebook to voluntarily take down
content you've mentioned that this has
been personally quite a stressful
process for you why is that well when
you fight against facebook we found out
you have to take into account that
Facebook will attack you personally
and you I also learned that there are
threats and that's really stressful
strenuous so I didn't think it would be
so difficult to go through court here in
richburg what kind of threats are you
referring to if you don't mind me asking
well they were serious of threats and
people asked me to discontinue my
activities against facebook else that
would be harm done to me or my family